>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Karen Heller: I'm Karen
Heller, national features writer
for the Washington
Post, a charter sponsor
of the National Book Festival.
The Library of Congress has
been the festival's host
since its inception
sixteen years ago.
We want to thank the cochairman
of the festival, David Rubenstein
and the many National
Book Festival sponsors
who made this event possible.
You can support the festival with
a donation by checking information
in the program and there will be
time for questions after the talk.
Harlan Coben is big, literally,
since 1990 he has written
thirty books that have sold
and this is a fact reporting
folks a gazillion copies
in uptillion countries, okay.
So he sold more than seventy million
copies in forty three languages
in more than 100 countries.
Harlan, how can he not be a writer
with a name like this born to dance
on the spine of the book?
He is the first author to win
the Edgar Award, the Shamus Award
and Anthony Award which means he
writes mysteries very, very well.
Harlan comes from that most exotic,
intriguing and art inspiring land
of enchantment, New Jersey.
That's true, nobody should put
New Jersey down for anything
because Maryland and Virginia
cannot claim what New Jersey can,
and we can go into
that another time.
He is a guy from Newark, New
Jersey a distinction he chairs
with the literary bard
of that city Philip Roth.
He still lives in New
Jersey unlike Roth,
he is also admired by the French.
His brace in 2001 thriller
Tell No One was made
into a terrific French movie
Nila D Appel Son [phonetic].
When Coben was nine
years old and living
in Livingston he met
a self-confident kid
in a catcher's uniform
who approached him
by saying Harlan Coben, hi,
I'm Chris Christie
what nine-year-old does
that Coben asked years later.
The lifelong friends disagree on
the single most important issue
of our time - which Bruce
Springsteen song is better.
Christie argues it's Thunder Road
and Coben swears it's Jungle Land,
for the record Coben is right.
Also, if I may indulge I have a
mystery idea for him; perhaps,
your next thriller could be
on the nation's busiest
bridge mysteriously closing
for some traffic study
the first day of school.
It's just an idea but I'm
giving it to you for free.
In 2013, he had so many
honors, Coben was inducted
into the Little League Hall of
Excellence with Chris Christie.
That same year he was also inducted
into the New England Basketball Hall
of Fame for his hoops
score in Amherst in college
and this is quite amazing, folks.
He was a member of the Psi
Upsilon Fraternity with Dan Brown
who also knows how to craft
a best-selling thriller
and shared a freshman dorm
hall with David Foster Wallace
who certainly knew how to footnote.
Coben's new book home published this
week has ace detective Myron Bolitar
investigating high
profile kidnapping
of two young boys a decade earlier
when only one of them returns home.
He was also at the first
National Book Festival.
Bolitar [assumed spelling] is
6 foot, not Bolitar, Harlan.
Bolitar is 6 foot four like
his creator like his creator
and a native of Livingstone,
a former basketball star,
a sports agent turned sleuth.
Also, perhaps most
compelling of all,
he's considered quite attractive
to women despite being
saddled with the name Myron.
Readers, friends: Harlan Coben.
[ Applause ]
>> Harlan Coben: Just got to adjust
this a little higher, there we go.
Thank you Karen, that
was really good, man.
It was like a roast, I was getting
a little afraid sitting here.
Hey, how are you guys?
Good. It's so great to be
back here in Washington DC
and I haven't even know where
I was actually born just north
of Washington in Newark, New Jersey.
So it's a thrill to be back
here amongst my people,
thank you very much.
So the book just came out,
it came out on Tuesday.
I do have a copy of it over here.
And so the book came out on
Tuesday and I usually do one
of those morning shows first thing
so this year I did
the CBS morning show
with Gail King and Charlie Rose.
And people always wonder
what's the best
and the worst part
being on the show.
The worst part is the teaser
like have you've ever seen,
they do stick the camera right
in your face and you're all
in your own room and they're like
coming up in the next half hour.
And you can't know what to
do and you're sitting there
and adjusting things, but
the best part of being
on those shows is I
get to wear makeup.
I look so good with makeup,
seriously I glow, I don't know.
So when I do that, I'm actually
tweeting this sort of thing,
I'm like wow, I look so good with
makeup, I don't know what it is,
so like you want to take a wipe
and wipe it off afterwards?
And I'm like "Are you kidding
and I'm wearing this all day.
I look great" and suddenly
I have four kids,
I am getting like emergency
text from my kids, right,
stop tweeting about make up.
If you follow me Hon any of those
things you will know which one
of my kids are because their
reaction to any picture I used
to you put up is either
one of three things.
Can you not?
Don't? And all in caps STOP
like an emergency thing.
In fact, I don't normally
do impression, I'm not.
I'm more known author as an author
than the guy doing impression
but I'm going to do a
quick impression for now
because when the books first
comes out I'm lucky enough
to get a full page ad, my
publisher gives me a full page ad
and at times a big picture like this
audit, yeah, I know, embarrassing.
So you can imagine my teenage
daughter's joy and pride
in seeing her father's picture
in the New York Times this big.
So here's my quick impression, is
my kitchen table in the morning,
the newspaper articles are here.
My daughter is coming down, she's
going to see her father's picture
in the newspaper as she is
going to school, here it is,
thanks, thank you, thanks.
In fact, oh, I got to
share, don't tell my wife,
I'm sharing this with you, okay?
Stole this, I stole this, I know,
we'll get to the books in a second,
don't worry, I promise,
we'll talk about books.
I have to share it with you.
So my, what's an actual
example of writing,
it's actually a great
example of writing
because writing you're
trying to sum things
up in a way that's entertaining
and economical, right?
So I'm about to, I snapped
this off my wife's song,
it says text exchange
between mother and daughter.
Just mother daughter mother daughter
and I think this is what I mean,
you'll see the relationship in
just these four quick notes, okay,
so let me read it to you and
don't tell my wife, alright?
Mother: Why are you home?
Daughter: Stomach wasn't
feeling well.
Mother: Oh mine too, diarrhea?
Daughter: Bye.
Do you get the relationship?
Do you see what I mean?
That's the wonderful thing
sometimes about writing.
Okay, I'm here to talk
to you about healthcare.
No, I am here to talk to you
about how to write, well,
I've nothing else I
can talk to you about.
So I might try actually if I can
to show you how I write the novels
and then we will take
a few questions
and please have you raise your hands
because if you don't raise your
hands and I'm just going to call
on you and not all of you
have done the reading.
Remember that?
Throwback, right?
So, first my Surgeon
General's warning.
You may not like how novels, a novel
is a little bit like a sausage;
you might like the final taste,
you probably don't want
to know how it was made.
That being said, here we go.
So, the first question we always get
is, "where do you get your ideas?"
Like just a boutique
on Dupont Circle
that sells them, you
know what I mean?
And the truth is anything can
stimulate an idea, tabloid headline:
boy 16 becomes grandmother, marries
Ed Asner, you know what I mean like?
Anything, you walk around all day
with your mind as open as it can be
and you ask yourself this is
the key to all writing, what if?
All the time what if and every
once in a while ideas get stuck
in these hooks in the brain
and it sort of stays there.
So I'm actually going to try to tell
you how to come up with a couple
of book ideas to illustrate this.
So a few years ago, I wrote a book
called Promise Me and the idea
for Promise Me came to be a little
bit serious here I overheard a
couple of teenagers talking
about drinking and driving.
And I pulled them aside
and I said maybe some
of you are doing same thing like
that, Promise Me, title of the book,
you won't get in a car with
someone's been drinking and driving.
Here's my phone number, I don't
care if it's three in the morning,
I don't care what you're on,
I don't care where you are.
I'll come pick you up, I won't tell
your parents just promise me you
won't get in the car with someone
who's been drinking and driving.
Now in real life that's it
and they still will never call
but fiction writing is
asking what if, what if?
A girl in New York City
calls my heroine, my hero,
have to make a promise like
this, he drives into New York,
he picks her up, he drops
throughout what he thinks is her
friend's house.
She's gone, no one sees
her ever again, what if?
That was the start of Promise Me.
Hold tight, friends confessed
to me that they're worried
about their kid, teenage boy fifteen
so they put spyware on his computer
to monitor what he was doing.
Part of me was repelled but that
part of me was like you have
to watch your kids the most and it
was like this is a cool grey area
and I can make a book out of it.
Again, what if?
What if they get a message?
That completely changed their lives.
Now, the problem of these
two examples is it sounds
like it took me back ten minutes
to come up with these ideas.
This is three months of
work, ladies and gentlemen.
This is three months to
sit in the couch going, no,
honey I can't throw out the garbage.
I'm working, can't
you see I'm working?
Hardest part of my job,
convincing my wife I have one.
The other problem with
this example is,
it doesn't quite get the mind
frame of how your mind just sort
of wanders and jumps around.
It's kind of like have you ever
had one those nights you can't fall
sleep because you're trying
to think of something?
Something really stupid like
you know, what's the name
of the dog in Petticoat Junction?
And you're sitting in bed,
and you're wondering what the
heck the name of that dog.
Was it Bobby Joe, Billy
Sue, what's the dog's name?
And then you're wondering "why am my
thinking of something so idiotic?"
And you try to trace your thoughts
back, you know, like bouncing all
over the place and you
are actually started
with something completely different.
You actually started with something
like why doesn't Burger
King serve Mountain Dew,
you know what I mean like?
Your mind just kind of
bounces about the place,
that's sort of a better
example I think of how you come
up with an idea and then I'm try to
now put that into another example.
I wrote a book a few years
ago called Tell No One.
And the idea for Tell
No One came to me
from two different directions, okay?
One and this is what I mean by
anything can stimulate an idea.
I was watching a really
crummy romance movie on TV;
I won't mention the name of the
movie "Message In A Bottle."
I love Nicholas Sparks, a good
friend of mine, but that movie.
Anyway, what struck me about that
movie was it's a story we've seen a
few times especially the ladies
will know what I'm talking
about where the man loses his
wife, right, the wife dies.
The man loses his wife
and he can't go on
and then a hot babe
walks by and he's fine.
Have you noticed that
in that movies?
In that case it was Robin
Wright, that kind of movie.
And I said to myself in
those moments I get serious.
What about the man that can't go on?
What about the man who's
truly lost his soul mate?
Is there a way I can
find redemption for him?
That's one part of the idea.
The second part of the
idea is I lost my parents
at a fairly young age,
yes, I get sentimental
and overwrite Myron's parents that's
what I imagine my relationship would
be with my parents.
If they survive if you
don't like the parts,
skip them, that's my therapy, okay?
Just leave me the heck alone.
But one day, I was thinking
the same way that we all do.
Wouldn't it be great if my
parents were still alive?
Wouldn't be great for my four kids
if they could meet
their grandchildren?
As I'm doing this I'm looking at
one of the street cams and I think
to myself "what will I do right now
if I saw my parents
on these street cams?"
Again, what if, right?
Now I took these two ideas
and I mash them together.
A man and a woman happily married.
Wife gets murdered, eight years
pass; he can't get over her death.
He gets an email, he clicks
a hyperlink, he sees a WebCam
and his death wife walks by.
And then the Homer Simpson part of
me goes "woo", that's the moment,
he's start kicking like a dog,
like you're being scratched,
right in that right area.
Again, three months of work,
ladies and gentlemen, three months.
Okay, so the next thing you'd
have to do, you have the sort
of concept, these sort of ideas.
It's first of all,
writers are a little bit
like we of the Hebrew faith.
Ask ten of them to
have to do something;
you get eleven different answers.
So they keep that in mind, every
writer does it differently.
I need to know the ending
before I start in every book
with the exception of one called
the Woods I knew the ending.
The Woods I had this
four kids in the world,
I didn't know what's going on.
I had to start the book about
a page a hundred and ninety,
one of the characters was kind
enough to tell me what's going
on because I was really
getting lost.
But normally I know the
beginning and I know the end,
I compared it to driving
from my hometown of Newark,
New Jersey just the
north of Washington D.C
across the United States over to LA.
I make a Route 80, chances are I
will go via the Suez Canal or stop
in Tokyo but I pretty
much always end up in LA.
Neil Doctorow has my second favorite
quote on writing he says that
"writing is like driving
in the night in the fog
with just your heads lights on.
You can only see a
little bit ahead of you,
but you can make the
whole journey that way."
So the only thing that
I would add is
that I know the end of the journey.
My very favourite quote on writing
and if you learn nothing else today
like you're learning something.
My very favourite quote on writing
is the best writing advice I have
ever heard comes from
the great Elmore Leonard
who said think about this.
I try to cut out all the
parts you'd normally skip.
Is that not genius?
And I try to do that,
I try to remember that.
Every page, every paragraph,
every sentence,
every word I ask is this compelling,
is the best I can do,
is this gripping?
And if it's not I got to
find a way of changing it,
it doesn't mean many kind
of themes or descriptions
or the larger things that's
supposed to be a novel.
But every one of those
has to be compelling,
I write as though there's a knife
against my throat and if I bore you.
I write as though we are cavemen,
we're sitting around the cave
and if I bore you, this
guy is going to pick a club
and wack me over the head with it.
That's the kind of energy I try
always to write with, you have to do
that at all times, if you can.
Alright, so, what do we have next?
Let me give you an example of what
I kind of mean by this by the way
if getting description
to whatever else.
Mary Higgins Clark tells
a story all the time also.
I'm a member of group
called the Adams Roundtable,
a bunch of mystery writers we meet.
It's supposed to be once a
month in New York for dinner,
ends up being a lot less
then that but members:
Mary Higgins Clark is a member,
Lawrence Block, Lee Child,
Nelson DeMille, Linda
Ferinstein, Susan Isaacs a lot
of great writers, very
talented people.
And one time a subject came up,
of what's the scariest
noise in the world?
Man being tortured, a woman
crying, a baby is screaming,
what's the scariest
noise in the world?
And one of our members goes
no, no, no, the scariest noise
in the world is you are
alone in a cabin in the wood,
you know you are all alone,
you are all alone in the cabin,
no one else is there and from
upstairs you hear the toilet flush.
That's the moment you're
always looking for as a writer,
the Flush Toilet Moment if you will.
So for setting for example, I'm
describing to you Route 23 in Wayne,
New Jersey by the way New Jersey
for some reason we have a lot
of mattress stores, do you
have that down here in DC too?
We have like Sleepies which
is the mattress professional.
And I was always wondering, is
that an MBA program, is that a JD,
how many years is to become a
mattress professional, anyway.
But if I'm describing to
you Route 23 in Wayne,
New Jersey I won't tell you
it's four lanes to cross
through the divider in the middle
lane but I find the one thing
so for example Route 23 in Wayne,
New Jersey there's a tattoo
parlor club, think about this.
Tattoos While You Wait.
[ Laughter ]
Like how else would you do it?
Here's my arm, put a little snake
on there, I'll be back around three.
That will tell you more than pages
and pages of dialog or description
on Route 23 in Wayne, New Jersey.
Also, in New Jersey we're
fairly honest people.
I'm not going to knock some of you
who are from close to this area,
but I was doing an
event not too far here
where the people kept telling
me when they go to the event,
they're going to cross
the Great Bridge.
Wait till you see the Great bridge,
you're going to love the
Great Bridge, keep mine,
I like the George Washington Bridge.
The Great Bridge is about
the length of this room that,
why don't you call it A
Little Piece Of Crap Bridge?
We have a motel in Route
17 in Ramsey, New Jersey.
One of those no tell motels,
thank you so much for nodding.
Has a sign saying "now
featuring towels", you know
and then also my favourite sign,
color TV like some people
have black-and-white still.
And the colors is always spelt
out like the c is in green,
the o is in red, the l is in yellow
like we don't know what
the word color is, right?
But I love this, because the name of
this hotel, this motel in Route 17.
It's the Fair motel.
We're not great, we're
not even good, we're Fair.
What do you want for an hourly rate?
That again will tell you
more about New Jersey
than pages and pages of dialog.
Oh, one more thing.
Sometimes with ideas, anger is a
great way of coming up with an idea.
Okay, so I wrote a book called
Just One Look a just a few again,
I'm sorry to get off course, I will
get back, remind me I'm on research.
Okay, so I wrote this
book Just One Look
and idea for Just One Look came.
I was picking up the family
photos at the Photo Matt,
you remember those things guys?
Some of you are old
enough to remember those.
So I'm going through the pictures
in the envelope and for a second,
just a split second, I
thought it was a picture
in there that I didn't take.
It turns out that the picture
is just upside down, oh,
but I had the idea what
if there was a picture
in the envelope I didn't take,
what if that picture
changed my life, okay?
But then you ask who's
going to tell the story
and for the first time I wanted
a woman to tell the story
because I've been reading a really
bunch, a ton of really bad women
in jeopardy novels, you know
the ones I'm talking about?
Where the heroine was like naïve
to the point of mental arthritis.
It's like gee, there is a serial
killer loose in the woods,
I think I will run to a secluded
cabin and not tell anybody
where I am going, not hook up a
phone line and hang out in my bra
and panties all day,
I mean people please.
In today's society, for
us to still be putting
up with that sort of thing.
So you guys I'm sure probably know.
There's a movie on the road,
we just changed people,
I'm going to really throw
you off now by taking to you,
I'm sorry, I'll forgot you're here.
So when I'm talking about
this woman in jeopardy thing
so I'm flipping along stations
because I'm a guy in the hotel room
and I'm on tour and I always to go
pass the Lifetime Movie Network.
And I'm not making this up, there's
been a remake of it but I used
to tell the story and
people wouldn't believe me
but I've seen this movie that
was starring was it Meryl Streep,
no, it's Tori Spelling.
I always mixed those two up
Tori Spelling and Meryl Streep,
but this was, this was, this was
Tori Spelling not Meryl Streep
and the name of the movie some
of you have probably seen this is
Mother May I Sleep With Danger?
No. This should be an awfully
short movie shouldn't it, right,
first of all the name is Danger, a
clue that it might not be for you.
Anyway, that anger, that wanting
to not have the story like that,
that wanting to have a heroine who
is real not the kind that goes "who,
there is a serial killer at the
door, honey, go get the door,
mommy is going to take a shower",
will inspire you sometimes
to write something better, okay.
So this setting, oh, research thanks
research, I'm on research, hold on.
So you're seeing writers here,
right, and they all talk probably
about research, do
a ton of research.
If your a writer in
the room my advice
to you is do zero research, none.
Thank you all very, very much.
I'm going to defend that
position now, okay, two reasons.
First of all, have you
ever read that novel
where the author's done a ton of
research and he keeps throwing in,
cute tit bits that he learned,
sort of slows the story down,
not a problem with me because
I don't know anything, okay?
Second reason, the more important
reason, research is more fun
than writing so you're using
research as an excuse not to write;
I see a lot of people
nodding their heads right now.
So it will be like, I'm going to
write a scene in Fifth Avenue,
New York, oh, but I can't write
it today I have to go back
and smell the hot dog stands
and watch the girls go by.
No, you're have an imagination,
you probably been there,
you can look at pictures,
write it now and then worry
about the exact research later on.
Don't let anything be
an excuse not to write.
Following on that, there are
three things that make a writer
and we'll go through
that in a second.
Well three things, two are
obvious, one is not so obvious.
The two that are obvious
are inspiration, well duh,
you need to be inspired to write
so let's just move that aside.
The second is perspiration
and that is doing the writing
and the only writing is writing.
Researching is not writing,
creating characters is not writing,
thinking about ideas is not
writing, outlining is not writing,
buying a new notepad is not
writing, going out with your friends
to Starbucks, eavesdropping,
none of those are writing.
Only writing is writing, only
putting actual words on a piece
of paper or on a computer
screen count as writing,
everything else his flotsam
and jetsam and nonsense.
So the only thing that
counts is your butt
in a chair producing words, okay?
So we have, oops, excuse me; we have
inspiration, we have perspiration,
but the third and the most
important thing a writer has
to have is desperation.
And that is I'm not fit to do
anything else like hold a real job.
I do have shoes; I
forgot to bring the socks.
I'm forgetful, I'm disorganized,
I'm sloppy, I have a tendency
to drift off, I go to never
never land all the time.
I go to fiction land; I'm
not good at anything else.
I was once on a panel with
a bunch of other authors
and we often get the question
if you weren't an author,
what would you be?
And one of my friends says a US
Senator; I'm like, oh, please.
I'll be a duvet cover I mean this is
it, this is all I got and that fear,
that worry, that insecurity
is what drives me back
to coach Steve Martins old line
being afraid that I have to wake
up at six morning and go
to the pharmacy and I had
to sell flare pens for a
living or whatever it is.
That fear drives me back still to
this day; writing is about fear.
I'm going to drop name
drop right now.
I had breakfast this
morning with Stephen King
and we both discussed the fact
that we still feel because I was
like I feel but insecure.
We writers never stop
feeling insecure.
I'll be writing my book like
okay I'm writing my book
and I'll be going Oh my God I
lost it, I was so good before.
What happened to me?
How did I lose it?
Five minutes later,
this is sheer genius.
Someone is going to read that ad
book, I'm not keeping this work
of Shakespearean proportions
really chanced five minutes happens
within five minutes one another.
When I finish a book I sound
like one of those game show host,
the voice services,
that's it for you Harlan,
there's no more ideas left.
You're going to get a real
job and here's some turtle wax
to go along with your new career.
Every book same thing, I've
written thirty books, thirty books.
One about one a year so I
started when I was seven.
Yeah, I wish.
But that never goes away, that fear.
The muse is not an angelic voice on
your shoulder singing beautifully,
it's your mom, well,
you don't be with me,
you'd rather be out
with your friends.
Come on Friday night,
no phone call, nothing,
that's what's there all the time.
And if you're a writer,
you always feel guilty even
when I'm reading, I love to read.
But even when I'm reading I
feel guilty I'm not writing.
There's always a voice
in my head that says
"you should be home writing."
If you don't have that voice
you're probably not a writer
and that's cool, I don't
need the competition,
seriously, it is always a voice.
Recently because I have nothing
else in my life other than my family
and writing, I took up golf.
Why didn't smash a
glass, pick up a chard
and stick it straight
in my eye I don't know.
Instead I took the less pleasurable
route of taking up golf but even
on those days when
it's beautiful out
and I'm doing okay
and hitting the ball.
There's still always
a voice in my head
that says "you should be writing."
Usually it's the guy I almost
hit with my errant tee shot.
Another question that writers
often get is "what's the bad part
about being the best-selling
author?"
You know, what's the bad part?
And I'm here to tell you, nothing.
It's as good as you imagine it is,
it's awesome and anybody who has,
it's bad karma man to
say anything negative
about being a best-selling author
because it's really the best,
and for me the other thing writers
say that annoy me, and if you're one
of those writers in the room
that says this I'm calling
you out as a liar, okay?
Or someone who needs a therapy.
Okay, here it is, the thing that
writers say that really annoys me,
have you ever heard of this?
I write only for myself, I
don't care if anyone reads it.
That's like saying I
talk only to myself,
I don't care if anyone listens.
From the beginning of time
since we could scratch,
oh, look I'm over there.
It's hard to capture my raw animal
magnetism in photography people.
You're better off looking here.
You know from the beginning of time
since man can write on cave walls,
writing has been about
communication,
right, that's what it's about.
So Berkeley's tree in the
woods, if I write a book
and no one reads it I don't
exist as a writer, you know.
This just came out; a writer
without a reader is a man
who claps with one hand.
I should clap here, claps with
one hand, you're the other hand
so this is the part
that is fun for me.
I'm throwing the ball,
you're catching it.
There's an Arabic expression
that when one man dies
a whole universe dies.
When one of you reads this book
a whole new universe of Myron
and Wayne and Esperance
and big-city comes
to life differently
than everybody else's.
A one-on-one connection
between you and me,
that frankly is the coolest thing
in the world to me and the fact
that I get to do this and
I get to meet you guys
who are reading the
books, that's otherwise
but the point, you know what I mean?
That's the magic of why
you're here, why we're talking
about books today at this thing.
Books still do that men,
what else still does that?
That spurs the imagination, that
moves you and enlightens you,
entertains you, what
else changes lives?
I was asked today about literacy,
and people are giving great answers
about how literacy, you need
it to fill out job forms,
and that whole economic reason,
but I'm just thinking imagine
your favorite books right now,
imagine your life, or how
intelligent you would be
if you never had a
chance to read this.
So I want to thank you all
for listening to me today
and I would be happy to entertain if
not answer a few of your questions.
Thank you all very very much.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Harlan Coben: We've
got about ten minutes
for some questions if you want.
Everyone's running out rather
than running to the microphone.
This is not a good sign.
Remember I said I would
just call on you.
Yes, go ahead.
>> I have two questions
I'm very interested in.
>> Harlan Coben: Yeah.
>> Second one you might have
to answer at book signing
so it doesn't give it away.
>> Harlan Coben: Okay.
>> And then.
>> Harlan Coben: I'm not answering
any [inaudible] no spoilers,
go ahead.
>> No, okay here's why.
>> Harlan Coben: I have to tell you,
I recently read this book I was
completely fooled by the ending.
[ Laughter ]
It's that stunning an ending, I'm
telling you, none of you is going
to guess the ending of this book.
>> I cried at the end.
>> Harlan Coben: Oh, good, I
want you to cry, you're supposed
to cry, good, good, good.
>> Quick question.
>> Harlan Coben: Yeah.
>> You usually write
a book once a year
and now it's only been six
months, will this be a pattern?
>> Harlan Coben: No, no.
>> Wrong answer.
>> Harlan Coben: My publishers
are listening and they know.
This year for some reason it's
hard to explain, I did two,
I had the idea for the Myron
Bolitar which is my first one
in five years very, very quickly and
I became obsessed with it and was
at it, wrote it fast
enough that they said "Woo,
can we get this done by now?"
and I'm like "yeah I think we can."
>> This one is not a spoiler.
>> Harlan Coben: Okay.
>> Because it right at
the beginning you see
when it's not with the Company.
>> Harlan Coben: Yeah.
>> What was Myron doing after
selling the Company for all
that time until Wynne got back?
>> Harlan Coben: I don't know.
You know, I don't respond
to anything
in this life that's not
necessarily in the book
but thank you for asking.
Gentleman over here, thank you.
>> Yeah, what a pleasure it is.
You talked about how you came
up with your ideas for
stories and things.
You also come up with some
very frightening characters
in your books.
Do you have, are those something
you're always thinking of as well,
particularly, tell one no
one Eric Wu was particularly
frightening [inaudible].
>> Harlan Coben: Thanks.
>> Just curious about how did
you come up with [inaudible]?
>> Harlan Coben: This is same
as regular people it's just
a little bit, you know;
you just got to twist
them just a little bit.
All my friends by the way always
think that the cool guys are based
on them, all my friends are
like that guy gets all the
chicks, that's me right?
Then we go that loser
with halitosis,
that's me right, they
never think that.
Yes, over here.
>> So in a lot of your books there
seems to be someone that's lost,
someone that people are
looking for and I was wondering
if there was anything in
your life that had kind
of propelled this idea
into your books?
>> Harlan Coben: Yeah,
I prefer missing people
because in missing
people there's hope.
Somebody is dead they are
dead, you just saw me crying
but missing people there
could still be alive.
There was a time in my
life before I was forty;
I had done seven eulogies
including both my parents,
maybe before I was
thirty five, seven.
Yeah so I had a lot of
loss and probably is part
of the reason why I'm trying to
find a way to bring back the dead.
That was deep, give me a moment.
Yes.
>> I'm student of French; I
started about ten years ago.
>> Harlan Coben: I hear your French
accent, is pretty thick, yeah.
>> [inaudible] it really.
>> Harlan Coben: I
expect that, yeah.
>> Really good one.
So I've been going to Paris for
the last ten years, once a year.
And I thought I might
as well pick up a book
that French people are reading and
each time it was a Harlan Coben.
>> Harlan Coben: Yeah, I'm a big in,
I'm the Jerry Lewis
of crime fiction.
>> You're very.
>> Harlan Coben: I'm hoping
that Germany will pick
up so you meet David
Hasselhoff also.
But right now it's
just the French, yeah.
>> It was very big.
Yeah.
>> They're an easy read.
I didn't need a dictionary,
everything was fabulous
until I hit one and it was clunky,
I couldn't read it and
I didn't finish it.
>> Harlan Coben: I hope this
is a going somewhere nice.
>> No.
>> Harlan Coben: I'm
teasing, just go ahead.
>> I looked, I thought "what is
the difference with this book",
and it was translated
by a different person.
Do you ever think that your books
rise or fall on a translation?
>> Harlan Coben: It's pretty
simple, if the books doing well
in a country I assume
the translator's good.
And if it's doing poorly
I blame the translator.
>> No.
>> Harlan Coben: It's
actually exactly,
>> Which is exactly what I did.
>> Harlan Coben: Exactly based
on translator, I once got,
my Japanese translator once sent
me a copy of the book and he said
if there's anything
in this translation you don't
like, be sure to let me know.
This symbol isn't capturing
what I'm trying to say.
Let's take two more questions
then will all go down
and sign books as fast as I can.
Yes, thank you.
>> First of all I love
your adult series a lot.
>> Harlan Coben: Thank you.
>> But I'm an eighth grade teacher.
>> Harlan Coben: Yes.
>> And there's a whole new
generation with the Shelter series
that we can't keep
them on our shelves.
>> Harlan Coben: That's so sweet.
>> They love them.
>> Harlan Coben: Thank you.
>> Is there going to be more?
>> Harlan Coben: Well,
I will tell you
that I think the kids are little
probably old enough, Mickey, Evan,
Spooner are all in this book
and we've learned a big secret
about one of their lives.
I don't think I'm going to go
back to the young adult novel
for a while, I wrote it as a trilogy
and I'm just so busy right now.
I'm doing two TV shows overseas also
that I don't think I'll have
a chance with the young adult
but just give it to me again and
tell them they never read it.
>> Well, I get a whole new
group each year every September.
>> Harlan Coben: That only
works with the older readers,
it doesn't work with the young ones.
One last, two last, both of
these two and then we're done.
Yes, thank you.
>> Could you address
the business side,
agents and publishers
and give us just the.
>> Harlan Coben: There
are all whores.
[ Laughter ]
No.
>> Can you dig a little
deeper and...
[ Laughter ]
>> Harlan Coben: I've
been very, very lucky.
All the people I've worked
with have been fantastic.
All the rumors you hear about like
that they want you to have more sex
in the books, or violence
in the books.
Each one of my books by the way
has less sex than the one before it
which also reflects my reality.
[ Laughter ]
Kidding, not really.
But I had nothing with great
relationships with my editors
and agents, find ones you trust.
I really could not do it,
everyone works for me like,
When I went to hire somebody I tell
them their job is just thinking work
I do it to free Harlan up to write.
All I want to do is to write,
I don't know about e-books,
I don't know that Amazon or Barnes
& Noble in the evils and sign this.
I just like as soon as I hear it I
go like, lalala I can't hear you.
What that makes me do is it
makes me just write harder,
I put my head down because the only
thing I can control is my book.
I can't control my Amazon ranking.
I can control how good the
next book is going to be,
and if that book is good enough you
guys will read it on stone tablets
so I don't have to worry
about the e-book or audio.
I try really to be as naïve
as I can about the business end.
Is that help it all?
>> Yes.
>> Harlan Coben: Alright, thanks.
Just write man, I'm
just telling you.
The only answer is always to write.
Yeah.
>> First of all thank you
for hours of enjoyment.
>> Harlan Coben: Thank you.
>> Really really [inaudible].
>> Harlan Coben: Thank you,
oh, that's very sweet of you,
that's very [inaudible]
thank you, thank you.
>> I was curious why your
books haven't been turned
into movies and if they ever are.
>> Harlan Coben: Yeah.
>> Who would play Mylan?
>> Harlan Coben: Tell
[inaudible] was mentioned
in the introduction really,
really good French movie,
was nominated for nine
of their Oscars.
It won four, for those
of you that have seen it,
I'm in it for about eight
seconds from the background,
I'm following Kristin Scott
Thomas and Françoise [inaudible]
like I said about eight seconds, no
line, but I was brilliant really I.
I stole the film; I was ripped off
for the best supporting
actor nomination
for assuming the French are
anti-Semitic, I don't know,
I don't have any excuse for it.
I did a TV show this year
in England called the Five.
I did, you know, Second
Chance in France,
Tell No One has a chance
of being made again.
It's an American remake, Fool
Me Once I'm working on right now
with Julie Roberts,
I love saying that.
I'm working now with Julie Roberts
like the two of us are hanging
out working on this movie.
I'm writing the screenplay for now
it's a weird, Hollywood is a weird
and destructive animal and it's hard
to really explain, other than to say
that I'm not too worried
about it because at the end
of the day there's always a James
Kay line when they asked him,
don't you hated what
Hollywood's done to your books?
She said "they did nothing
to my books they are
right there on the shelf."
Thanks everybody very much.
I'll see you downstairs.
Thank you, thank you.
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov